he came to power unexpectedly
martin biscara was sworn in as peru's
president in 2018
after pedro pablo kuczynski stepped down
amid allegations of corruption
now after a tumultuous time in office
viscara has been ousted
lawmakers accuse him of moral incapacity
for allegedly receiving
more than 630 thousand dollars in bribes
for public works when he was a governor
in peru's southern region of
martin viscara said there was absolutely
no proof of the allegations and denied
any wrongdoing i have my head up high
you know very well that i never run away
i hold in my hands the arguments for the
truth
less than two months ago viscara
survived a previous attempt to remove
him over claims he'd interfered in a
corruption investigation
in september before the first
impeachment trial the government filed a
lawsuit at the constitutional
tribunal to clarify what moral
incapacity means according to the
constitution
but the justices said they will not have
an answer before december
allowing lawmakers to make their own
interpretation of the law
analysts say lawmakers have undermined
peru's political system
this is the end of democracy for our
country we have turned into a banana
republic where the rule of law is a joke
and lawmakers think they can unseat a
president just because they have votes
martin biscara leaves office after
confronting some of the worst political
upheaval in recent history
seven cabinets changed at least 60
ministers resigned
viscara dissolved congress last year in
an attempt to push
forward political and education reforms
evidently this created a great animosity
from the traditional political class
toward president viscara who didn't have
a party
and in peru when a president is orphaned
of political support
in congress the rule has been that those
governments end really bad
or with the coup d'etat martin viscara
fought congress amid the worst
health and economic crisis in peru for
more than a hundred years
to the end he maintained he was the
victim of an opposition plot
following his own efforts to introduce
anti-corruption reforms
live now to mariana sanchez in lima
viscara came out to speak in the last
hour what was his reaction
that's right imran martin viscara was
flanked by members of his cabinet in
front of the steps of the presidential
palace he gave a last goodbye to
peruvians he
has said goodbye he said he was going
home
but that he disagreed with the result of
this vote
and that he has always been transparent
he said he would not take any legal
action
and that he was now going to face
justice and prove
everyone wrong he has said all along not
only today but throughout these past
months
this during this impeachment and during
the past impeachment uh proceedings
a month and a half ago that he has
uh denied throughout this time
any wrongdoings and that well
and that he will prove everyone wrong in
the meantime
a lot of peruvians are now angry
in uh the last few polls uh we have seen
that
peruvian supported president martin
viscara and now people are protesting
the streets of
lima some also in the city of trujillo
north of
lima and in other places with just in
few people there is a curfew here in an
hour
because of the pandemic so possibly we
will see more people on the streets
tomorrow
i remind you that it's uh 80
78 of peruvians who have supported
viscara all along and have said that he
should stay that he should have stayed
until
july of next year we have elections
general elections
in jan in april and that he should stay
and face justice after that people are
angry
95 percent of peruvian say that he must
be
uh investigated and prosecuted but
uh but at this moment a lot of peruvians
are angry
and possibly will see more people in the
streets in the next few hours
thank you mariano sanchez life for us
there in peru